AJ is preparing for a very dangerous
opponent on September the 22nd Alexander
Povetkin has also failed to drugs tests
so is it right he gets a shot at the big
time so soon after a doping ban I think
is Brad you know I don't condone you
know drug cheats and stuff like that you
know I don't make the rules I don't I
just know I've got to keep myself clean
I will keep myself aboveboard can you
trust him because it is failed to drugs
test this guy Justin we decided to do
this campus and is we actually pay for
extra drug testers you know to travel
around the world with all my opponents
cost a lot of money but I think it's
better to be safe than sorry and then I
put myself up for it my opponent has to
put himself up for it we have friendly
cash because it's an independent drug
agency that go around to do random drug
tests and I'm sure Povetkin once
approved that he's clean as well and we
were fair and square you've had to take
this fight because it's a mandatory and
you couldn't get the Deonte Walter fight
sorted out in time but Tyson Fury did
manage to get that fight on all they say
they have as he stolen your Thunder
later no it's about the long term you
know I'm happy that they've taken the
fight I think they both needed it you
know they've been professional ten years
and they both need meaningful fights
dante wilder strategy is fight Tyson
Fury and beat Tyson Fury boost his name
me and him will get it on providing a
beat Povetkin Tyson Fury strategy is put
some money in the bank after a three
year layoff and continue talking rubbish
as he does what did you make of the
Logan Paul Karras I fight two youtubers
trying to be I'm trying to be a bug that
credit to him why it was actually a good
scrap and you know what if it brings
like a lot of ice to the sport boxing a
lot of like kids youtubers gamers and
now watching boxing and benefits I saw
so I'm all for it to be honest do you
see yourself as a peacemaker you know as
a force for good
even though ironically you fight for a
living yeah I see myself as a force for
good I don't know about for Humanity
because that's a massive task in itself
would there be peace that's a great
question people have been fighting and
dying for that for years but in terms of
like what I spread around my small
circle yeah man we bring a lot of peace
good vibes and positivity and that
that's what matters isn't it I may not
be out to conquer the world but and
definitely try and put my little touch
on the people down around and that I can
affect such a lovely iog do you ever get
close to snapping we were still Mourinho
last week snapped in the news conference
start ranting on about respect
did you ever kind of think oh I've had
enough yeah definitely Joe I respect
rememory know forty done though because
was talking about it he took a lot of
the attention away from the players
mistakes people were busy talking about
Mourinho rather than talking about the
players that didn't do their job so I
think he's a great manager in that sense
so I think I can definitely flip but I
like Mourinho I'm more tactical with it
now and as have you reasoning behind it
so I don't think he just flipped because
he was annoyed I think he fought you
know what I'm gonna put this man in his
place then also my players didn't
perform my said of them like crucifying
him and him and him they're gonna
crucify the manager and it takes the
heat off of the pressure so they can
focus relax they're not reading all the
negativity in the press and they can
focus on their next game and grant
perform so I think it was that's like
he's still aggressive and like myself
but we're just a bit more tactical of it
is there any downtime for you
there's there any real downtime you know
because everyone's always got a camera
haven't they everyone's a cameraman
these dates but you have to be a
professional 365 oh yeah you do have to
figure out the thing clever you have to
be clever by feeling that where I grew
up I finger you know it keeps me on my
toes
you know and I've always had them and
tell you anyway so that side of things
doesn't really affect me cuz I've always
had more wits about me to know me but I
think yeah nowadays war news cameras and
stuff anyone anyone has to be careful
because it's easy to make mistakes
it's hard to rectify them you know I
mean one mistake can change your life so
you've gotta be on your toes to fear
anything I mean it might be not boxing
to do with boxing might be spiders died
in early died in early really yeah Diane
young yeah definitely
why'd you think about that because are
you all gonna go
[Laughter]
no one's escaped it if you ever meet
anyone send them my way
won't you most look forward to after a
fight it's weird like you know in the
ring after it's a it's like a bit of
relief it's weird like remember your
what I always know that I'm walking
around the ring with the belts handing
out their belts and like spotting people
but it could easily be the opposite way
you know and that you're in there and
like you've just as owned in with your
opponent and you're thinking I can't
afford to make a mistake and I just
think all they're waiting for is for me
to make one mistake so I'm going for
every second of that there's three
minutes in each around thinking I won't
be switched I will be switching of what
we switched on and then when I win that
feeling that after five feeling is I got
a job done you know it's just like a
honesty like a big relief cuz I think a
lot of people want to see me victory
sometime when they see me flat on my
back and that's normally the way it goes
in their way but sint what do you look
forward to you know is it in ice cream
so laughter that part of my training
knock another nasty food wise that food
wise would be brownie and ice cream
apple crumble and ice cream and then
actually the holidays I love to travel
it's like some Sun some beach like it's
like you live this different lifestyle
when you're on holiday I like to like
wake up fresh fruits
pouring to music it's like the day just
goes so slow and perfect you know you
can watch the sunset well watch the
sunset from my flying surfboard that's
not on my mind so I just live a
different life something definitely look
forward to holiday we've seen loads of
sports people involve their children in
their big
forty moment you know footballers like
to bring the kids out on the porch it's
all Novak Djokovic he was so insistent
that his little boy who's three had to
be there at Wimbledon to see him pick up
the trophy can you ever see you know
being comfortable with your son watching
you fight yeah I don't know why why it's
why I do he was watching it the other
way know was that that looks like you he
was watching it wasn't they were saying
that guy looks like me which was funny
but yeah it was me but the thief
fighting is that guy looks like you
comfortable watching yeah definitely he
has to know what I do I still understand
the struggles more than anything taking
him to the fights and stuff not so
important my mom doesn't come and niece
doesn't come my dad goes my sister but
what I like to do is maybe just keep it
separate so like I'm dad I'm not the
fire I'm not the champion I'm just dad
at home you know I mean so they respect
me for that and that's the way I like to
keep it to be honest but he would
definitely be aware of what I do
wait took to get there and I'll reflect
that in life in general not just in this
war and that's what I mean that's the
dad advice not just the boxwood way cuz
I don't want him to be a boxer what's he
gonna be there maybe accountant
I wouldn't mind him being an accountant
I don't mind good with numbers crunching
numbers